all right so I'm pretty sure at least
eight percent of the comments on my
recent Batman reviews were where's
Batman mask of the phantasm Oh a
theatrical release it's a great movie
and you know what I agree with you
wholeheartedly in an all-new
larger-than-life feature film The Dark
Knight confronts his newest and most
menacing villain is your angel of death
awaits phantasm I warn you now if you
guys didn't know every once in a while I
like to do this segment called an
overlooked review it's a movie that I
think is great but not too many people
know about or just isn't recognized as
much as it should be and Batman mask of
the phantasm is exactly that before
Batman Begins came out this was actually
my favorite Batman film it was released
theatrically in 1993 was based off
Batman the animated series such a great
television show if you have not checked
that show out it is Batman the way he
should be I recently picked up volume 3
of the show I've been watching it it's
it's so good it's such a great show if
you haven't checked it out check it out
please and now we get a theatrical
version of that show and you know I
remember when I was a kid and I first
saw this movie in fact you know what let
me show you something this is what
dreams are made of right here
VHS clamshell case oh that smells like
when I was a kid I I such nostalgia
right here as I was saying when I was a
kid I watched that movie like every day
honestly every day really and I memorize
each lines sound effect everything in
this film you have this character called
the phantasm he's this masked guy and
everyone thinks he's Batman because
they're only getting glimpses of him but
the thing is he's going around murdering
crime bosses and as we know Batman
doesn't kill we see Batman trying to
solve this mystery who is the phantasm
well at the same time the city of Gotham
is being turned against Batman because
they think he's gone absolutely rogue
and it's just killing people so not only
does he have to flee from the police and
protect his reputation but he has to
figure out who is this guy who's killing
all these people now one of the really
clever things this movie does that I
love is it has a lot of flashbacks to
the past and it's actually the very
first time we ever saw in the theaters
Batman's origin story because in Batman
and Batman Returns he was Batman from
the start Batman mask of the phantasm
told through animation
Batman's origin and it's actually very
very interesting with lots of character
depth and really good action sequences I
would be insane not to bring out shirley
walker's incredible score for this movie
who unfortunately has since passed away
she won an Emmy for her work on the TV
show and this score honestly is
oscar-worthy it is such an excellent
score the movies like 77 minutes long so
it's really tight I mean every scene in
this movie matters everything needs to
be there and from scene to scene to
scene there is not one dull moment in
this movie it's almost non-stop complete
action whether the really great dialog
or suspense or just a flat-out action
scene it's so great to see the past
story of Batman told well you know you
get to see like his first encounter with
some thugs he's got his ski mask on and
he's not quite Batman yet but he see his
first failure you see his first love you
get to figure out how Alfred and him had
a great origin relationship and how he's
like a father figure to him this is
honestly very similar to Batman Begins
in a lot of ways it's just this
animation it's a lot shorter this is
honestly one of the best Batman movies
out there it's my favorite one besides
the Nolan one's the Joker is in this
movie as well voiced by Mark Hamill yeah
Luke Skywalker who in the world would
have ever thought let's get the guy who
played Luke Skywalker to voice the Joker
but dearly
he's great his laugh is great he's great
his laugh is perfect it's just it's so
awesome it's funny I feel bad for him
kind of you seen a lot of Comic Con
videos where people just asking him to
do the laugh and that seems like all she
does is sign Star Wars pictures and
laughs like the Joker but hey he's good
at it man one of the things that's so
cool about this movie is those
characters you know the character of
Batman is the way he's supposed to be
he's a dark brooding character he is the
Dark Knight in this movie he cares about
the citizens of Gotham he's not just
some showy superhero who wants to go out
and get into some whimsical adventure he
is a dark messed-up psychological
character and it really shows in this
movie from the writing the look of the
movie also is really impressive it's got
this total 1940s film noir thing going
the animation is so cool how it makes
this
look really murky and dark but it just
the colors and the life that are
portrayed through this animation it's
such a great world that they made for
Batman it really evokes the feel of the
darker Batman comics another thing
that's so great about this series and
this movie is Commissioner Gordon and
his relationship with Batman they
actually have a detective crime solving
relationship where they help each other
solve crimes and mysteries their
relationship together is great it's how
it is in the comics how they solve
crimes together it's how it was
portrayed in the Nolan films is the way
it should be Batman mask of the phantasm
to this day in my opinion was the first
theatrical Batman movie to get Batman
right at least an animation form thank
goodness no one came along and made it
right in live-action as well
you haven't seen the film I implore you
check it out it's excellent if you
haven't seen the Batman animated series
it is just as good I'm gonna give Batman
mask of the phantasm and a definitely
check it out if you haven't yet can't be
too careful with all those weirdos
around the Soaring new adventure zak-man
mask of the phantasm the animated movie
well guys I have now reviewed every
Batman film except the 1966 Adam West
Batman and I'm sure someone who will
want me to do that too it's a funny
movie I grew up with that one too
I loved that movie but I'm not gonna
review it it is however a good movie
thanks for watching guys and as always
if you like this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck my
knives
[Music]